over 17 million fathers in the u.s.
inventive fathers wouldn't wave not
everyone knows who their father is
for 40 years we thought we did until
today I wasn't sure who your father was
how does that work - crazy selfies
everybody was high in [ __ ] Oh
monogamy wasn't exactly a priority Wow
I've always wondered where I got my zest
for lovemaking now we know our fathers
been out there this whole time operation
who's your daddy the top mission is
signing dad submission is gonna be
having Stone Crabs mission below that
getting you laid mom actually dated
Terry Bradshaw do you remember a woman
named Helen Baxter talk about a blast
from the past
she had the tightest ass you've ever
seen in a set of tits really know how to
use them if you know what I mean she had
a mouth I mean that tongue almost cost
us the Superbowl she's our mom why did
you just stop this foolishness
this is it what are you doing here
anything were your sons excuse me for a
minute
he runs hot just like you give the man a
ride you could easily be a serial killer
got a nervous Nellie here are you a
serial killer I am NOT a serial killer
you just emphasize the word serial like
I'm a killer but I'm not a serial killer
but that was totally an intense you're
still not saying I promise I'm not a
killer we can give you a ride but those
aren't too tight are they almost kill
you
[Music]
who is that I think who's a person the
universe has a tendency to point in the
right direction of gifts guys my negro
spider sense is tingling
does the name Helen Baxter ring a bell
it does more than ring a bell I think I
just gave my pass no damn man that woman
go [ __ ] she was like a dick whisperer
she's our mom all we did was cook hey
you want to see someone who can catch
hit me on a Bob
[Music]
[Music]
you